la bataille de casselle de 1328
immortalisé lors d'une visite singulière
dans le cadre de l'opération Tous en
faête la Fondation Française des jeux et
la CroixRouge organisait mercredi une
journée d'action solidaire au château de
Versailles 315 personnes s'étaient vu
réserver la galerie des Batailles le
temps d'une représentation
[Musique]
théâtrale c'est intéressant parce que
c'est pas seent qu'on on va au château
et tout ça je pense que ça peut être
bien ça va être ça va être bien même
s'il pleut dehors on va s'amuser moi je
suis venu toute petite donc ça me fait
plaisir de revenir je trouve que c'est
très enrichissant et de faire tout ça
après des périodes de Noël je trouve ça
assez festif enfants et adultes s'étent
inscrit dans les diverses antennes de la
Croix-Rouge d'Île de France et de la
Manche pour ce spectacle au programme
goûter visite de la galerie des glaces
et des grands appartements du roi et de
la reine l'avantage de cette opération
tout en fait c'est qu'elle réunit tous
les publics bénéficiaires de la
Croix-Rouge c'est à la fois
effectivement des familles qui sont dans
des situations difficiles ça peut être
des personnes âgées des personnes en
situation d'handicap le château de
versaill qui souhaite ouvrir ses portes
à tous les publics inaugurera bientôt un
ascenseur pour les personnes handicapées
et multiplie ce type de manifestation
c'est la troisème opération de ce type
que nous faisons avec la fondation de la
Française des jeux dans l'année nous
avons accueilli une visite ané par emus
une autre visite dans le cadre des
Journées contre pour la prévention de
l'autisme et bien nous essayons de
jalonner notre année avec des
manifestations de ce type des
manifestations de solidarité de son côté
la Croix-Rouge française organé chaque
année 300 événements en France du 1er
décembre au 15 janvier environ 50000
personnes bénéficient de ces
actions